alors vous m'avez adresser votre
candidature car vous recherchez un stage
c'est ça un stage de deux mois dans la
cybersécurité un profil qui tombe au bon
moment le dirigeant de cette entreprise
informatique de versailles cherche à
recruter actuellement 10 nouveaux
collaborateurs ingénieurs techniciens
mais aussi commerciaux dans la
maintenance et la sécurité informatique
ce stagiaire pour l enrichir ses équipes
même poursuivre en alternance est allé
jusqu'à signer un cdi et le bilan de
l'entretien semble être positif là je
lui laisse remplir un test technique
mais je pense que mon l'acceptera et on
va l'intégrer on va le former on va le
faire grandir faire grandir des jeunes
stagiaires une solution pour faire face
aux difficultés de recrutement notamment
dans le secteur du numérique mais les
entreprises doivent encore aller plus
loin il ya beaucoup de demandes on a un
secteur qui est très dynamique et
effectivement on peine à recruter
aujourd'hui à trouver des ressources
formés et disponibles en plus une
rémunération intéressante ban aux
candidats la plupart auront à leur
disposition un véhicule une mutuelle
intéressant des tickets restaurant où on
est au maximum du plafond du plafond
légal la possible de participer aussi à
des événements sportifs plusieurs fois
dans l'année entièrement pris en charge
par le groupe ce phénomène de
difficultés de recrutement concerne de
nombreux secteurs économiques plus
complexe encore pour les activités de
niche à forte technicité
c'est le cas de cette entreprise
industrielle spécialisée dans la
fabrication de prototypes de recherche
et développement elle recherche
actuellement quatre nouveaux
collaborateurs on essaie d'avoir des
entretiens mais c'est pas assez pas
évident parce que bon on va en soit en
ce moment il ya une forte une forte
demande certains jeunes
ne voit pas forcément l'industrie dans
leur coeur pour pour travailler les
écoles techniques sont moins en mois à
former des jeunes et c'est pas évident
de trouver de bons profils ou des gens
qu'il ya aussi les gens qui veulent
continuer à ces difficultés vient
s'ajouter un phénomène engendré par la
crise sanitaire la grande émission le
fait pour des collaborateurs de
démissionner et de se reconvertir dans
une nouvelle activité